the national transportation safety board
determines that the probable cause of
this
accident was the pilot's decision to
continue flight under visual flight
rules
into instrument meteorological
conditions which resulted in the pilot's
spatial disorientation
and loss of control a final word from
the investigation into the helicopter
crash that killed kobe bryant and 13
year old daughter gianna
as well as seven others last january at
a press conference on monday the
national transportation safety board
announced they've completed their full
report on the tragic accident
and that the investigation is now closed
here's what we learned following their
year-long investigation into the tragic
accident the ntsb
said there was no evidence of internal
engine failure in the helicopter
contributing to the accident was the
pilot's likely
self-induced pressure and the pilot's
planned contin
continuation bias which adversely
affected
his decision making and island express
helicopters inadequate review
and oversight of its safety management
processes
robert sumwalt chairman of the ntsb
stated the pilot ara zobian
flew into the clouds a violation of
federal standards
and then likely developed spatial
disorientation
meaning he couldn't interpret the
helicopter's position in relation to the
earth
or any other points of reference we're
talking about
spatial disorientation where literally
the pilot may not know
which way is up or down whether he or
she is leaning
left or right in addition the ntsb noted
there was no evidence that island
express helicopters
or kobe bryant himself were at fault for
zobian agreeing to fly in the
challenging weather conditions that
morning
this could complicate the wrongful death
lawsuit filed by kobe's wife
vanessa bryant in march 2020. the
lawsuit alleges zobian made multiple
errors and that island express
helicopters had
advanced knowledge of his unfitness due
to a previous violation in 2015.
in court documents obtained by e.t
vanessa is asking for substantial
compensation
claiming their family lost hundreds of
millions of dollars in earnings
from kobe's death this solemn update
comes just one day after the bryant
family received some news worth
celebrating
eighteen-year-old daughter of vanessa
and kobe natalia has signed with img
models
the famed talent agency shared the news
on monday and posted a stunning photo of
the bryant's eldest
child in a statement natalia said quote
i have always been interested in fashion
since a very young age i have a love for
the industry and ever since i can
remember
i wanted to model there is a lot to
learn but i feel this is a great
opportunity for me to learn
and express myself creatively proud mom
vanessa quickly shared the post on her
instagram account
writing i'm so happy for you i love you
nani
you